The Expendables for or expend 4 Bulls if
you like reading things literally is the
latest in this series of over-the-top
old school action movies Sylvester
Stallone beginning with the first
Expendables has managed to convince some
of the biggest action stars of all time
to be a part of this incredible movie
franchise and the fourth installment is
no different in honor of kicking butt
and taking names four times over let's
take a look at some of the behind the
scenes well action from The Expendables
Jason Statham is more than your average
tough guy action star he's a man of many
talents including stunt driving Statham
is known for doing a lot of his stunts
especially any that involve driving so
when it came to doing his own driving
stunts on Expendables 3 Statham jumped
at the opportunity and for the most part
things went swimmingly but on one scary
day things went well swimmingly cause
let's face it even the most skilled
stunt drivers can have things go wrong
while filming Jason was driving a truck
that was supposed to come to a stop just
before the water's edge on a harbor but
things did not go as planned we did a
run through
and his brakes did not it was a
potentially horrifying and traumatizing
thing to witness
sitting there like oh my God I just
watched a person die but amazingly Jason
managed to get out of the truck into the
water and emerge unscathed one thing
people were quick to mention was the
fact that in his days before being an
actor Jason was quite an accomplished
diver he represented England in the 1990
Commonwealth Games and came close to
qualifying for the Olympics so perhaps
this type of accident was one that was
best suited to Jason who was unlikely to
panic from taking a dive into the water
even from inside a truck and maybe the
most incredible thing about the whole
ordeal was that Jason kept right on
filming we're at Chase's clothes hop
right back in the truck satham isn't the
only true Pro in The Expendables
franchise Sylvester Stallone has been
the driving force behind the series
since the beginning and it's fascinating
to see how sly's work ethic and
attention to detail permeate pretty much
every facet of the process take a look
at this footage of Stallone getting into
the nitty-gritty of how the demolition
process would work for the final scene
in the first movie I've wired the entire
building in a way that a demolitionist
expert in Las Vegas would wire a casino
that has to come down they're not going
to explode if they're imploded he also
has enough experience on the sets of
action films over the years to know how
valuable it is to get everything right
the first time because having to reshoot
scenes especially ones that literally
need to be rebuilt and then re-exploded
can take a long time AKA it can get very
costly very quickly so Stallone is
pretty direct about this that guy is no
pressure this has to be perfect on the
first take and his attention to detail
extended all the way to the background
round actors Stallone wasn't about to
let even one background actor not look
realistic like in this scene where he
addresses the actors playing soldiers
who were lined up ready for battle Sly
knew that even if these characters
weren't in focus on camera the overall
look needed to be perfect you have to
stand like soldiers you're not like this
so be alert and Stallone was meticulous
in his choreography for all the fight
and shooting sequences too his years of
training on so many action films really
paid off as he was able to coach his
fellow actors with Precision to make The
Expendables look as amazing as possible
then you then you stay there until I say
hey and then you turn around you get
blast it Stallone can take more than a
little credit for the evolution of the
action star and in particular he
essentially created the archetype of the
Silent Action star in a clip of behind
the scenes footage on The Expendables he
talked about a specific reason this
happened apparently he absolutely hated
the first cut of First Blood so much so
he tried to take matters into his own
hands before anyone could see it can I
buy the print because why so I could
burn it the producers declined his offer
and instead they agreed to make some
serious cuts to the movie to make it
flow better this meant cutting a lot of
dialogue including a lot of what
Stallone had said as John Rambo and
while you might think a movie star would
scream bloody murder if like 70 percent
of their lines got cut Stallone loved it
the movie's run time was cut from 3
hours to 89 minutes Stallone loved it
and audiences did too according to Sly
but that's what sold it that's what
that's the whole concept of that silent
character which wasn't silent
true story Flash Forward through the
years since this action classic and you
can trace this type of Silent Action
star archetype all the way to the
Expendables movies and Sly is still
around playing them and yet Stallone has
maintained that even in classic action
movies like The Expendable series there
needs to be more than just action in
creating this franchise he emphasized
the importance of showing the humanity
in all these Action characters it's hard
sometimes for an action actor to show a
sensitive side and because of that we
care about the characters a lot more and
are willing to go on the journey with
them through so far four movies of
course being a tough guy is still a
prerequisite for starring in The
Expendables and not just playing a tough
guy character actually being tough in
real life over the years Stallone has
been injured numerous times while
filming and The Expendables was no
exception in the first one he was
instructed by his doctor to literally
stop filming and shut the whole
production down for a couple months
while he let a ruptured tendon heal
sly's response pretty much exactly what
you'd expect from a man who has made a
career out of not only acting but being
tough questions whether you can do the
stuff you need to do
he also sustained a serious injury while
filming the third movie Stallone had
what's known as a back blast while
filming and he needed surgery to repair
it but despite his many injuries he has
a pretty hilarious take on the movies
that go along with him said Stallone I
grade the quality of a film by the
intensity of the injuries when I shot
stop or my mom will shoot I never got
hurt threw Rambo and The Expendables I
break my neck and my spine and I
dislocate both shoulders he further
joked that if people hear squeaking
while he's moving around set it's not
his shoes making the noise but the metal
surgically inserted in his back of
course Stallone is far from the only big
action star in the franchise Dolph
Lundgren plays Connor Jensen and while
it's a serious character in a serious
movie Dolph has a pretty light-hearted
view of his character according to
Lundgren Connor has a few vices he
managed to sort of become part of the
team of this picture instead of being
this kind of offbeat character in the
first one and he insisted that playing a
Swedish drunk was actually a lot of fun
plus he was equipped with a weapon or
two that perhaps made the other stars
jealous the biggest knife of everybody I
think and uh I'm the craziest
but even with the goofing around on and
offset the cast and crew definitely felt
the pressure of continuing the quality
of the franchise ETS interview for The
Expendables 2 Terry Crews talked about
how sequels have so much pressure to be
bigger and better everybody's waiting to
see how much bigger and better and the
way it's different is that it is bigger
and better this wasn't just an attitude
The Producers took some big bold steps
to make sure the sequel popped in new
and better ways for starters they added
in action Mega stars like Chuck Norris
and Jean-Claude Van Damme to the cast
plus they started getting bigger and
better with the stunts too we actually
shot in Europe and basically blew up
Bulgaria in many many ways that country
will never be the same the stars of The
Expendables all have to be bigger and
better too and that means staying in
incredible shape and when you're
prepping for a movie like The
Expendables you often don't have the
luxury of building your muscle up over
time because the shoots are often not
that long after the project is given
given the green light Dolph Lundgren
talked about how one of the things you
learn when training for an action movie
is to adapt your training regimen to be
super efficient and you also get really
good at the balance of training and
shooting plus these actors know how to
stay fit and ready for the next projects
you know when you do four months in the
picture like we did we kind of know how
to simplify your workout there's also
the friendly competition aspect when it
comes to looking buff on camera doll for
example pointed out that when you're
gonna be opposite other action Stars
known for their size it can feel
daunting you had to stand next to this
guy over here now this fool over here so
I have to build up a little more muscle
one thing Stallone loves about the
franchise is that while they're modern
films they also have a throwback vibe in
how they approach the action sequences
what's the action films today are very
highly Technical and so the Expendables
try to bring back a little that old time
rock and roll it's also how they
approach the casting of the film as
we're all aware so many of the cast
members are action Legends and many of
them have been making these types of
movies since the age of rock and roll
that Sly was talking about as the man
who basically brought the entire
Expendables franchise from an idea to a
reality Stallone is certainly aware of
how important and difficult it's been to
get all these Mega stars on screen
together he's always been very cognizant
and respectful of the level of action
Stars he's dealing with in The
Expendables franchise as such get them
all together at one time is a minor
miracle makes it very special because
you're never ever going to see this
again even though Sly and Company stayed
true to their old school action Roots
when it came time for Expendables 3 they
knew some things had to adapt and a big
way to do this was to bring in a younger
set of Expendables I think it has a
little bit of everything it you know
it's a throwback but then again it's
monitor because you have the young
Expendables Calvin Lots who played one
of the young Expendables seemed to be
able to jive with the older action Stars
pretty easily when asked what it was
like to be in a movie with a Mount
Rushmore of of action Stars Kellen
jokingly said I didn't care about us
Young Guns they just threw us in they
called us different names so I would
call me Ronda all the time so it seems
like there was not only a level of
respect that the younger cast had for
the Legends but also a playfulness back
and forth that allowed everyone to put
their egos aside and just focus on
making a great product that included
getting input from a source who doesn't
exactly scream action star Kelsey
Grammer of course grammar who played
Bonaparte in the third movie has had a
stellar career of his own with more than
enough experience to have legit opinions
on dialogue he talked about how he felt
comfortable making dialogue suggestions
to Stallone and the producers we sit
down and say you know I think this
Line's not so good and then Sly would
take it in stride even joking but then
he'd say yeah that's from an old draft I
don't know about you but I'm planning to
buy an extra large bucket of popcorn to
check out the fourth installment of this
insanely fun movie series of course
that'll also mean I'll probably want an
extra extra large drink which might mean
a bathroom break hmm I've got some
planning to do in the meantime if you
have any thoughts about the upcoming
Expendables movie or about behind the
scenes fun from the first three pop them
in the comments section